[Musique]
c'est à la grotte des premiers français
que le président du département cyrille
melchior a rencontré huit familles suivi
depuis plusieurs mois par les
professionnels du gul de saint paul de
saint gilles les hauts
ses parents défaillants dans l'exercice
de leur autorité parentale font l'objet
de mesures des mots d'action éducative
en milieu ouvert demandée par le juge
des enfants aux mesures mises en
comptera le département qui vise à
rétablir la place éducative des parents
et à renouer les liens familiaux bas la
principale difficulté comme on travaille
sur d assistance éducative en milieu
ouvert donc ici ont des mesures
éducatives judiciaire c'est la question
de l'adhésion puisqu'à la base dans 90%
des situations là les familles qui sont
très réticents puisque le juge des
enfants qui est un peu cette mesure
d'assistance éducative nous les envoient
entre guillemets en mission dans des
contextes qui sont souvent hostiles
donc vraiment le challenge de départ en
se basant sur les objectifs fixés par ce
juge
c'est d'arriver à gagner la confiance de
famille et puis crée un lien tisser ce
lien qui va nous permettre ensuite de
cheminer sur un total de ces trois
dernières années ont permis de punir 53
main levée de mesure des migrants et une
augmentation significative du placement
des enfants confiés à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
nous avons 7 sur 7 sans éducateur dans
le domaine de l'accompagnement de la
famille de la partie globalement
globalement je le dis bien pour
renfoncer sur le territoire de la
réunion toute la politique familiale
c'est un budget de poids de 100 millions
d'euros chaque année consacrée et
l'adorent vous avez tout ce qui touche à
l'amélioration de l'habitat
vous avez tout ce qui touche à la
parentalité vous avez tout ce qui touche
aux bourses poids que les enfants
puissent réaliser leur étude
donc c'est un budget conséquent
que nous mettons à disposition des
familles d'allocs nous démarche
innovante oppose d action collective
permet aux familles de se retrouver
d'échanger de partager selon pris plus
de 24 corps se trouvaient dans cette
situation n'a voulu rien quoi on veut
plus rien et d'autres observons plus
rien on s'entend comme on peut mais
après quand je dis ça aujourd'hui mais
revu et il rapporte à nous de lait coûte
déjà de l'aide
et puis il fait à ma table rassemble à
nous rencontrer d'autres parents mes
petits-enfants et rencontrer d'autres
enfants chose que chez moi y'a pas et
puis moi même y rencontre d'autres
parents j'avais envie de voir autre
chose de voir ailleurs le baiia parce
que à un moment donné là quand surtout à
mon âge
à mon âge trois petits-enfants la
cinquantaine trois petits-enfants c'est
pas évident mais pas évident à madame
parce que maintenant temps de
recommencer ma vie
mais bon c'est la faute à man
ben
la confiance a confiance en moi
leur confiance en optique un sombre et
puis 24 et santa
recréer un petit peu la famille quoi
famille et un second avec cointreau de
communication est bon c'est vrai tout
son appétit 10 ans mes vidéos google
tu vois là d'après quand même quelque
chose
une action qui traduit la politique de
prévention menée par le département chef
de file de l'action sociale et
l'évolution positive de situation
[Musique]